there are millions of kilometers of
empty space around our earth
and even if we ever manage to accelerate
to speeds more or less equal to the
speed of light
it is highly unlikely that we will ever
get to reach planets
harboring intelligent life forms but
actually even closest space
objects may harbor some organisms which
evolve in harsh conditions we would deem
unfavorable for life
one of such places may well be titan's
freezing surface
or to be more exact its oceans
concealing quite a few riddles
and mysteries
apart from the earth titan is the only
celestial body in the solar system with
liquid on its surface
unlike our earth however this liquid
isn't water
but a mixture of liquid hydrocarbons for
the most part
methane and ethane oceans on titan were
first seen in radar images
which were beamed back by the cassini
probe on the 21st of july 2006.
in the period from 2004 to 2017
the space probe approached titan on 127
occasions
thanks to these photos scientists were
able to successfully map
out the entire surface of this moon in
fine detail
analysis of the relief and its features
revealed that the same processes were
instrumental in its formation both on
titans and the earth's surfaces
the only difference lies in the fact
that water was the main factor for
relief formation on our earth
whereas on titan it was liquid
hydrocarbons
as a result titan's surface is also
covered by lakes
seas rivers and bays just like that of
our planet
it also rains there on a regular basis
too
titans lakes of the most part rather
vast
but not really deep their number
reaching 650
the biggest of them are referred to as
seas or mares
and they have been dubbed after mythical
sea creatures kraken mare
lygia mre and pangamare
there are dunes on titan's equator which
is explained by the fact that the
climate in that area is the driest
these areas account for seventeen
percent of the overall surface of this
moon
with mountains and labyrinths making up
fourteen percent
and one and a half percent respectively
most of titan's surface
or 65 percent to be precise is covered
by planes
as for mountain ridges they stretch for
several dozens of kilometers
with a height reaching several
kilometers
only 23 impact craters have been
discovered on titan
their diameter over 20 kilometers which
is not more than 0.4 percent of the
total area
most craters are believed to have
disappeared due to highly intensive
erosion processes that have been taking
place for several hundred million years
due to some organic compounds which
include atoms of nitrogen
titan and its atmosphere are of an
orange hue
now let's talk about big liquid objects
on titan
the area of kraken mare the largest one
discovered on its surface
is approximately 400 000 square
kilometers
and its length measures about 1170
located in the satellite's northern
hemisphere this body of liquid is
estimated to be up to 200 meters deep
the second largest body of liquid on
titan lygia mra
is also situated in the northern
hemisphere with its width measuring
about 500 kilometers and its depth
reaching up to 170 meters
lygia mre covers an area of
approximately a hundred thousand square
kilometers
the third and the smallest sea on titan
pangamare
is also the most northern of the three
its diameter measures approximately 380
kilometers
these seas are most likely to be made up
of liquid methane and ethane
as both gases are rather abundant in
titan's atmosphere
regularly forming dense clouds
it must be due to evaporation of methane
and ethane from the
surfaces of these maoris that these
gases can be found in the satellite's
atmosphere
there are some dark spots to be seen in
images of titan's surface
they are likely to be drifting chunks of
ice that have emerged from the bottom
as a rule this kind of hydrocarbon ice
floats in temperatures
close to 183 degrees celsius below
zero if the temperature drops still
lower
nitrogen bubbles in the ice rocks will
account for less than five percent
which makes these rocks sink it is also
highly probable that in some areas of
titan there may be an ice shield
enveloping liquid methane both below and
above
it's worth mentioning that the chemical
composition of the liquid
on titan is different depending on an
area
since it is liquid gases with different
boiling points that account for most of
the liquid on titan
the chemical composition largely depends
on temperature
for example the chemical composition of
the liquid of the pills is different
from that at the equator
which is warmer apart from bodies of
liquid on the surface
there may also be a subsurface ocean of
impressive proportions on titan
and for all we know it may contain water
this hypothesis was put forward as an
inference from this idea
following saturn's tidal effects the
core may get heated up
and a high enough temperature may be
sustained for liquid water to be formed
under titan's surface
besides cassini's images from 2005 and
revealed that some features of relief
had shifted approximately 30 kilometers
since titan is tidally locked to saturn
that is it faces it with the same side
at all times
this shift may be accounted for by the
fact that titan's ice shell is separated
from the main body by a global liquid
layer
the subsurface water is thought to
contain a considerable amount of
ammonium which acts as an anti-freezing
substance
thus decreasing the water's critical
freezing point
coupled with a high pressure from
titan's crust this may be an additional
favorable condition for the subsurface
ocean
this ocean may well lie as deep as
approximately a hundred kilometers
with its water rich in various sorts
this liquid
is most likely to be a mixture of salts
and its chemical composition
includes salts containing sodium
potassium and sulfur
the depth of the ocean is different
depending on the area of titan
with liquid freezing and forming an ice
crust in certain areas
the exceptionally high sword
concentration makes it too harsh an
environment to support any life
as for titan's land there is a chance of
encountering
simple life forms on its surface
titan's atmosphere is rather dense and
chemically active
containing diverse organic compounds
this allows us to assume that there may
be life in the atmosphere's upper layers
it seems feasible that simple organisms
could be sustained by gas
hydrogen and also consume molecules of
acetylene
after digesting these in return they
could produce methane
it should be mentioned that relatively
recently highly active organic molecules
were discovered in titan's atmosphere
the substance in question is called
cyclopropanilidine
this is an unstable and highly active
material which cannot be observed on
earth
anywhere but in a laboratory environment
scientists
first came across it in 1985 and clouds
of interstellar gas in space
cyclopropanilidine is crucial in forming
larger organic molecules
its discovery on titan was the first
case of finding it in the atmosphere of
a planet rather than an interstellar
environment
this discovery will certainly help
scientists to see titan's chemical
evolution from a different angle
there are also some alternative theories
about life on this satellite
according to these there could also be
life forms in liquid methane rivers
but this is feasible only on condition
that these organisms live on hydrogen
rather than oxygen
and produce methane rather than carbon
dioxide unlike organisms on our earth
however since titan does not lie in the
goldilocks
zone and its surface temperature is as
low as about 180 degrees below
zero these hypothetical organisms would
differ a lot from those
were used to see on our planet
lipid cell membranes for instance which
are typical earth dwellers
wouldn't be able to survive in such
conditions
some really bizarre analogues would then
be produced by evolution processes
and we can't venture even a wild guess
as to what they would be like
be it as it may climatic conditions on
titan really are
able to sustain certain forms of
microbial life
this is the main object of interest for
nasa's dragonfly spacecraft planned to
be launched to titan in 2027 to
investigate
and who knows perhaps this mission is
destined to reveal
something even more fascinating than
we've already found
out the search for alien life forms is
undoubtedly an arduous task
that will probably not yield any results
until the next millennium
but its global significance can hardly
be overestimated
if at some point we succeed in our
attempts
this will be a major milestone and the
beginning of a new era
in the history of mankind it will not
only allow
humans to enhance their own knowledge
but also begin a long
and scrupulous process of fostering
relationships
with intelligent beings from another
world
dear friends we try our best to make
every new video better
your support by electronic likes really
boosts our growth
i hope you enjoy learning about the
limitless expanses of our universe with
the cosmo channel
if you'd like to see new fascinating
videos feel free to hit the like button
and subscribe if you are new
on our channel there is so much exciting
stuff up ahead
let's keep in touch
you